[DRUMMING]
Good morning.
And what a beautiful
morning it is.
Welcome to the 363rd celebration
of Harvard commencement.
I'm Diana Eck, a professor
of comparative religion
and Indian studies
here at Harvard.
I'm joined in our tree house
by Professor Dan Schrag, who
is a professor of geology
and the head of the Harvard
University Center
for the Environment.
It is a really great day.
The people are streaming into
the Tercentenary Theatre, where
we're seated.
We have a great view and are
looking forward to spending
these next few hours
with you, as you
have the best
seats in the house.
So get a cup of coffee
or tea, put up your feet,
and enjoy the
commencement exercises.
So Diana, it's really
spectacular today.
Not only is the
weather magnificent
after a long, cold
winter in Cambridge,
it's just clear
and beautiful here.
But actually, it's
thankfully not too hot.
Last year we were sweltering
in 90 degree heat.
It was.
It was incredibly hot.
And this year, it's
just-- everybody looks
excited and happy.
This is such a special
day when you look out
and you see all of
the PhD students
and professional students filing
into the Tercentenary Theatre.
You see all this
potential for the future.
What's wonderful about this
day and this celebration today
is that it's both looking
back and looking forward.
There's a lot of hard
earned history here.
As you said, this is
the 363rd commencement.
And there'll be lots of
aspects of this day that'll
include talking to the
50th reunion class,
or the 25th reunion class.
But really, what today is
about is looking forward,
looking at all of
these students who've
worked so hard for the last
several years, sometimes two,
three, four.
In the case of PhD
students, even more.
And here they are
now working, going
forward out into the world
to really change the world.
They are our future.
It is commencement.
In that sense, it
is a beginning.
And with trepidation, and
with hope, and high optimism
for the future, everyone
is beginning a new phase
of their life, all of these
graduates who are here today.
That's great.
And we actually are joined right
now by one Harvard graduate.
She is in the class of 2014.
We have Valerie Shen here.
Valerie Shen is in Cabot House.
She is graduating in both
environmental science
and public policy, and in
earth and planetary science.
I know Valerie
because she actually
took my course as a freshman.
And was wonderful.
And then ultimately
worked in my laboratory,
did here senior thesis with me.
She won a Hoopes
Prize for her thesis.
Congratulations.
And is graduating summa cum
laude and Phi Beta Kappa.
Congratulations, Valerie.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Thank you for all of your help.
So Valerie, tell us a
little bit about today.
You came in with all
of your classmates.
When you look out there,
what do you think about?
Well, I think about all
the wonderful opportunities
that Harvard has given us,
all the great friendships
that we've made,
the amazing mentors
like yourself that we've had
the opportunity to work with.
But also, all the
opportunities that we all
have for the future.
And being part of the
Alumni Association,
being able to meet
alumni around the world,
and the great jobs and
internships that we've all
had and will continue to
have throughout the rest
of our lives.
So Valerie, who's
here with you today?
I mean, what family do you have?
Where do you come from?
So I'm from Madison, Wisconsin.
And both of my parents, Ben,
and children are here with me
today.
My younger sister,
Kelly, is here
and my boyfriend,
Jamie, is also here.
It's a very exciting day.
And you know, what's wonderful
about today is there are just
hundreds of thousands
of students, each
with their own story,
each with their own path.
Now, Valerie, you're
heading off to first travel
a little bit in Southeast Asia.
Yeah.
I'm very excited.
I haven't seen a lot of
the world, I feel like.
So going around a couple of
countries in Southeast Asia.
Also going to Japan and
China for a little bit.
And then I'm going
to be starting
work full time in September
out in San Francisco.
Now, you're following
an interesting path.
You were very interested
in energy issues,
environmental issues.
You've worked on climate
change for your senior thesis.
And yet, you're heading off
into the business world.
Tell me a little bit
about what you're
thinking, about how
your path is going
to be improved after
you leave Harvard.
Sure.
So I think the business world
will be really exciting,
because I'll gain a lot of
very valuable skills there.
I think a lot of the work to
be done in energy and climate
change can be done through the
private sector with clean tech
companies leading the way.
And I think that after a few
years in the business world,
I'll be able to go get a MBA.
And I'm also going to be getting
a Master's in Environment
and Resources at the same time.
And with that and my
business experience,
really be prepared to make
change on climate change
issues, especially if I want
to go into the public sector
or even continue in
the private sector.
Valerie, it's very,
very exciting.
It's wonderful.
And I can't think of a more
important area to go into.
So congratulations.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations on today.
And good luck with those dreams
in the future, because this
is really important work.
Thank you.
Thanks for all your support.
Congratulations, Valerie.
Have a great day and enjoy it.
Thank you very much.
Bye bye.
So this really is a ritual
transition for everyone.
And the processions
that brought people
from their houses or
their graduate school
this morning in great
battalions are really
the processions toward this
great rite of transition
that takes place here in
the Tercentenary Theatre.
This is a ritual passage.
It is a rite of
initiation for everyone.
That's right.
And what's wonderful
is that both classes
of old and the
current classes all
take part in this celebration.
So very soon, we'll see the
25th and the 50th reunion
classes coming in.
And they're special people.
Each one of these
classes is really
made up of remarkable
individuals.
What we're beginning to
see are the processions.
And we will see the procession
of the alumni as well.
But you caught a glimpse a
moment ago of the president's
procession, which is moving
through the open ranks
of the seniors in
the freshman yard.
The houses are lined up with the
processional path between them.
And the president's
procession is the first.
We'll see it several
times before they
enter into the
Tercentenary Theatre
and take their
places on the stage.
That's right.
And of course, with the
president in addition
to the various deans and
leaders of the university
are also, of course, the
honorary degree recipients,
who we will talk about later.
And there are the
members immediately
with the president, the
members of the corporation.
Here you see some of the
honorary degree recipients,
if one can recognize
them, just a glimpse
of them with their
faculty escorts.
The members of the
corporation will
sit with the honorary degree
recipients, and the president's
party, and the
faculty on the stage.
One member of the
corporation, Susan Graham,
is a professor of computer
science at Berkeley.
Very distinguished
computer scientist.
And she is a member of
President Obama's science
advisory council with me.
I know her very well for that.
And she's celebrating a
very special day today.
It's her 50th reunion
year at Harvard as well.
So she not only is
on the corporation,
but she's also with the
50th reuinion celebration.
That's splendid.
And several of our colleagues
are in that 50th reunion class
as well.
Marshall Ganz from
the Kennedy School.
Marshall, really
extraordinary individual.
He was a class of
'64 slash 1992.
Yes.
Because he actually left
Harvard before he graduated.
He didn't take part in
commencement that year
in 1964, because he
went down to the south
and worked for the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee.
He did.
And then he worked with Cesar
Chavez as well in California.
That's right.
He was Cesar Chavez's right
hand man in the Farm Workers,
and did that for many decades.
And ultimately came
back to Harvard,
finished his undergraduate
degree, got a PhD,
and now teaches at
the Kennedy School.
What a tremendous story.
And Sheila Jasanoff,
of course our colleague
also at the Kennedy School, one
of the founders of the Science
Technology Studies discipline.
Brilliant scholar, fabulous
teacher and mentor.
She's also celebrating
her 50th reunion today.
That's a wonderful note as well.
Here we see the various
processions starting.
I see various faculty
coming through.
Faculty members coming through.
Of course, all of the different
colors and the pageantry.
I see Peter Bol from East
Asian studies, Rick McCullough,
our associate provost.
The deans.
There are several of the
deans of different schools
here as well, members of
the president's procession.
Dean Pfister, who
just passed, who
has been the interim
dean of Harvard College
during this year.
There's Mike Smith, dean
of arts and sciences.
You see all of the different
colors representing
the universities where
they got their PhDs.
All wonderful different colors.
Described by one wonderful
person at the 300th anniversary
of Harvard as a flock
of iridescent birds
in so many different colors.
We see quite a lot
of crimson here,
but the other
colors of the Ivies
and other great
universities as well.
There's a picture of all of the
undergraduates getting ready.
You can see them watching.
And it's really a
wonderful tradition
where the faculty
file through the ranks
of the undergraduates.
It's just a spectacular feeling.
I'm up here with you
on the stage today
in front of the
television camera.
But I sort of miss filing into
this theatre through the ranks
of the undergraduates, and
having them applaud you
and vice versa.
It's just a wonderful moment.
And just reaching
out to see that there
is the president coming past
Lowell House, the President
and Fellows Division.
She's accompanied by the
members of the corporation, whom
you see behind her.
And that corporation has
grown just a bit larger
in the last few years.
And I love their
hats, I must say.
They have spectacular hats.
The tall hats, top hats.
Scarcely-- not
very many contexts
in which the top hats and the
broad brimmed hats of the women
are as visible as here.
There's Eric Jacobsen
from chemistry.
Dan Lieberman from human
evolutionary biology.
All sorts of
wonderful colleagues.
This is such a spectacular--
You might say they're straggling
rather than processing.
But that's good.
They're making their way.
And there's President
Faust who will soon
be stepping onto the stage,
which is right beneath us here.
The crimson gowns of
the PhD graduates,
they will be
acknowledged almost first
in the recitation of the
conferring of degrees.
Yeah, it's a very special honor.
The PhD is really, it's
the ultimate achievement
here as a student at Harvard.
Really at the point
where now, you
are joined the ranks of
an independent scholar.
They're qualified to teach
and be a professor anywhere
in the world.
590 PhDs being awarded today.
My colleague Peter Galison, our
friend from history of science,
tells me that their
small department actually
had 16 PhD graduates from
history of science this year
in the class.
Really quite extraordinary.
That is extraordinary, and a
very, very important field,
that's to be sure.
Here in this-- well,
what some people call
Harvard Yard between the
Memorial Church and Widener
Library, this was renamed the
Tercentenary or Tercentenary
Theatre in the 300th
anniversary of Harvard in 1936.
There we see Alan Garber
there on the left.
Alan is the provost, of course.
And he has his PhD In economics,
and an MD as well from Harvard.
And those empty
chairs on the right
will contain the undergraduates
as they file in house by house.
The graduate schools
are already seated here.
They gathered in [INAUDIBLE]
Quad a little bit
earlier this morning and
began their procession
with the PhDs, and then all
of the other graduate schools.
One of the amazing
things about this day
is that it's the only time that
you see Harvard as a whole.
I mean, Harvard University
is a word, really,
until you see this incredible
gathering on commencement day
with thousands, 10s of
thousands, 32,000 people
somehow in these quadrangles.
Well, it's really an
extraordinary collection
of knowledge, an
of eager students with
incredible ambition,
incredible potential
to change the world.
And I see that in
thinking about issues
related to energy
and environment.
When I look across
these schools, all
of these students-- I've
come across so many of them
over the last several years.
And they're going to
go off around the world
and literally change the world.
It's very exciting.
And they really come from around
the world in so many ways.
At least in their generation,
their parents' generation,
their grandparents,
if the grandparents
of all of these graduates
could be here today,
it would be a global
village to be sure.
That's right.
And of course, what you
see also in the background
is a lot of parents as well.
And of course, it's
important to remember
that behind every student is
several family members, perhaps
parents, perhaps
other relatives.
But really, who help them
get here all the way.
And this is an achievement
not just for that individual,
but of course for
their entire family.
It's very, very special.
Some of our students
come from families
who've never been to
university before.
Others have long histories
connected with Harvard.
But whatever the background,
whatever the connection,
our students really are a
testament to the parents,
and families, and
all their support.
And this day is as much
for them as for all of us.
One of the things that's
quite remarkable every year,
but especially in
the last 20 years
as Harvard has become
so much more global,
is the baccalaureate that the
undergraduates have took place
yesterday in the
Memorial Church.
Or Tuesday, rather.
Oh, here the undergraduates
are starting to file in.
Here they begin.
And it began with a
reading from Confucius
in Chinese and then English.
And then readings
from the Bhagavad Gita
in Sanskrit, from
the Hebrew Bible,
from 1 Corinthians in Greek,
and from the Quran in Arabic.
I mean, this is
the linguistic base
of the sacred texts of the
members of this graduating
class.
And it's an
extraordinary testament
to what has happened to
the stock of the Puritans,
as fair Harvard puts it.
The stock of the
Puritans has expanded
to include people from
all over the world.
And this is an extraordinary
testament to that.
It's true.
Globalization is
really not just a word.
It's here at Harvard.
And it's very exciting.
And if you look at the deans of
the Harvard Graduate Schools,
who we will hear from, they
come from all over the world.
Xiao-Li Meng of GSAS
of Chinese background.
And Nitin Nohria of the
Harvard Business School,
who is of Indian background.
And Julio Frenk, the School
of Public Health, from Mexico.
From Mexico.
And of course, Mohsen Mostafavi.
From Iran.
From Iran, from the GSD.
And the new dean of
Harvard Divinity School
is from Northern Ireland.
So the flock of deans is really
an international and indeed
a group of people with
a global perspective.
And I think that is one
of the hallmarks of what
is happening at Harvard today.
Not only all the world
in this small place,
but a sense of
global consciousness
among the students
and faculty here.
So here come the faculties.
Now, we don't separate the
faculties in this sense.
All our colleagues
are all mixed together
across all the
different schools.
It's so true.
I mean, the faculty line up.
They're supposed to,
I mean undergraduates
are told, they're supposed to
doff their hats as they pass
the statue of John
Harvard, which we just saw.
I'm not sure how many
of them still do that.
One of the things that is
great about this ritual
space, the Tercentenary
Theatre, is
that there's so much
of individual student's
history that takes place here.
For the AB graduates,
the undergraduates,
they come here-- and in
recent years have come here--
for their freshman convocation.
And then there are all sorts
of great public events.
There was the yard fest where
Janelle Monae, who sang almost
at the same time she
sang at the White House,
came here to be the
lead entertainer.
An extraordinary event.
And major speeches by people
like Al Gore took place here.
That's right.
Al Gore came here to
celebrate the Harvard's effort
and commitment to
sustainability at Harvard.
This is also a space that's
used by the students for things
like political rallies.
It is indeed.
So this is a place where
student activism and student
political speech
really is center stage.
And that's part of the
vibrancy of this place.
Here we see some of the
PhD students coming in.
All of these students,
believe it or not,
and their families
will be fed somewhere
after these exercises are over.
There'll be processions
and movements
back to the various
buildings on campus,
and to all of the
huge tents that
have been set up everywhere.
There is virtually an
alternate campus of tents.
Well what's so lovely is that
Harvard is really in full bloom
right now.
I mean, the trees, the
leaves have come out
in the last few weeks.
And the grass is green.
The grounds crew has been
working incredibly hard.
It's been pretty cold.
But it's amazingly special.
I was just talking
to Ned Friedman, who
was the director of
the Arnold Arboretum.
The Arnold Arboretum
is in spectacular--
Glorious.
--glorious time right now.
The rhododendrons
are almost out.
And it's really an amazing time
to go see the Arnold Arboretum.
It's a very special place
attached to Harvard.
But really, this entire
campus as a botanical
display right now.
But I must say, if we had been
looking out over the crowd
yesterday afternoon during the
time that the undergraduates
were having their
class day, you would've
seen people who were-- there
is Sheila Jasanoff, by the way,
and Jay Jasanoff.
Oh yes.
And Jay Jasanoff
for 50th reunion.
Some of the faculty coming in.
Yes.
But the parents were all sitting
in their coats with their hoods
on.
And the students as well,
except even those on the stage.
It was extraordinary.
It was chilly.
When they all came
back to the houses,
we had a reception for all
the Lowell House parents
and graduates
yesterday afternoon.
And they were cold.
We served them a bit of wine.
But they also wanted a
little tea and coffee,
because they had
been sitting here.
It was a wonderful
afternoon, though.
And I must say, the
words of Sheryl Sandberg,
who is the CEO of Facebook,
were really extraordinary.
She has written this
great book, Lean
In, but with it a lot of
advice for students about it's
not a ladder that you climb up.
These days, it's more
like a jungle gym
where you have to be very
flexible and move from side
to side as you make
your moves in life.
And that you never know
what you're going to be.
She said, when she
graduated of course,
she had no idea about Facebook.
There was no Facebook.
In fact, there was no internet.
So the world changes fast.
And I think the flexibility
is really extraordinary.
Yes, that's right.
Now Diana, you're
a house master.
And house master, for those in
our audience who don't know,
really plays a very
special role at Harvard
for the undergraduates.
The undergraduates live in the
houses, they eat in the houses.
The houses also play a role in
their intellectual development.
Absolutely.
All sorts of activities and
events that you organize.
So seeing them
off and graduating
a class of seniors
from Lowell House
for you must be both
wonderfully satisfying,
and also a little bittersweet.
It is bittersweet, as
this day in general
is bittersweet for all of us.
I think for faculty,
for house masters,
for graduates, for our
tutors in the houses.
But it is true that the houses
are not, we have to say,
they're not simply dorms here.
They are inter-generational
communities
of faculty and of tutors,
who are in graduate school,
and undergraduates.
And we have lots of events.
I think you came to one of the
master's dinners this year.
That's right.
I came to a dinner and had a
long discussion with students.
I was so impressed with how
curious the students were
and how engaged they were.
I mean, we've had-- this is
a tradition that's great.
These are opportunities
in the houses
to have a small dinner or a
small discussion gathering
with, in this case, the
likes of Dan Schrag,
or this year with
Justice Souter, who
is a member of our
senior common room.
And with David Gergen, and
with members of the faculty
throughout.
Just a wonderful chance.
Those kind of
opportunities to interact
with faculty members
outside of the classroom,
really in these more special,
more intimate encounters,
that's a very special part
of the Harvard experience.
Well, and it's
one of the reasons
that I love being
a house master.
I think it's the
best job in Harvard.
You're not supposed to
be out raising money.
I mean, although
we do need that, I
should remind our audience.
But it's an opportunity
to be with students
outside the classroom.
And some of those students
are in your classes as well.
But it really is fabulous.
You eat with them,
you live with them.
You deal with them in hard
times and with glorious times.
So you really get to know
them in a very special way.
Yeah.
One of our great
traditions at Lowell House
is Thursday afternoon tea
where Dorothy and I pour
tea in a silver
teapot to all comers.
It started out as a
Lowell House event,
but actually we have
literally 200 students
from all over the college who
want to be served a cup of tea.
It's a civilizing
influence as well, I think.
What a wonderful tradition.
That's great.
It is great.
So I think we're getting close.
We're ready to begin.
We are getting close.
It looks like the
undergraduates are--
Undergraduates are--
--mostly in.
They're continuing to file
in and take their seats.
Seeing this
gentleman in a turban
reminds me that in
yesterday's baccalaureate,
there was also a reading
from the Guru Granth
Sahib from the Sikh
scriptures, really
for the first time in my memory.
Well some of those seats on
the right are still empty.
So we have a little time to go
before they are all filled in.
One of the things that
is totally in evidence
here are the literally
thousands of cell phones
on which people are
snapping their pictures.
This is-- Drew Faust tried to
talk a bit about this yesterday
in her baccalaureate
speech, where she says,
you are the class who entered
in 2010-- what's sometimes
called the year
of the smartphone.
You tweeted and
buzzfed it all as
you instagrammed your selfies,
viral tagged your Pinterest
accounts, and monitored
your Twitter feedback.
And then she said, I
hope I got that right.
Yeah, I think that Drew is
not of a generation that
uses all those social--
That's instagramming selfies.
We're not doing that
either at the moment.
But I will say that this
is a generation where
the selfies of dozens
of students, they've
really developed long enough
arms to take group selfies
and send them instantly
to their friends.
This class of graduating
seniors this year
is filled with
special people, people
like Valerie Shen,
who we met earlier.
Some of our colleagues
also have children
in the graduating class.
This year, for
example, Kathy Buckley,
one of our associate
provosts, her son Tom Miller
is graduating from Adams House.
He concentrated in psychology
with a secondary in government.
And congratulations to
Tom and to Kathy Buckley.
It's wonderful.
And there's so many stories
like that, our colleagues
and our friends
who have students.
There are also many
distinguished friends
of Harvard who are in their
25th reunion class as well.
My friend Ariel Anbar from
Arizona State University,
and Lisa Dilling from the
University of Colorado,
those are both
earth scientists who
are back here for
their 25th reunion.
Scott Nathan, who's
a friend of Harvard,
led Baupost Investment
Firm in Boston
and is now working in
the State Department,
Scott has been incredibly
generous with his money,
but also with his time,
working tirelessly
for a variety of
environmental issues.
And now, he's
working in Washington
in the State Department.
And also, Jonathan Shaw,
who is the managing
editor of Harvard Magazine.
Jonathan has been
a wonderful force
at Harvard Magazine
for many, many years.
His father was actually
my father's roommate
at Adams House in
the class of 1959.
Jonathan Shaw is celebrating
his 25th reunion today as well.
Congratulations to him.
Here, we see pictures of the
band playing the last few notes
before we get ready to start.
What will happen once the
sheriff of Middlesex County
calls this meeting to
order is that there's
almost nothing
that is unscripted.
There's a small booklet
that is almost like a ritual
manual for the marshal
of the university.
Marshal Jackie O'Neill is
the chief ritual officer,
so to speak.
And all the words that
the president speaks
and that the deans of
the various faculties
speak as they introduce
their students, all of those
are part of that script.
It's very traditional.
It changes a bit
from time to time.
But on the whole,
this is a festivity
that is both utterly
chaotic and rather ordered.
There you see Dean Ellwood
of the Kennedy School,
and Jackie O'Neill on the
bottom left, who is our--
There's David Ellwood--
--marshal.
--dean of the Kennedy
School talking with--
With Drew Faust again.
With Drew Faust.
Now, of course, as
the ceremony proceeds,
President Faust will
bestow the degrees
en masse for most
of the students.
The deans will get
up individually
and ask the president
to bestow the degrees
that the students have earned.
And she will do it en
masse with one exception,
the undergraduates who graduate
summa cum laude, the highest
Greek honors that
they can receive.
Very small number of
them in each class.
They will actually come up
and receive their degree.
The summas are asked to draw
near as the undergraduates are
introduced.
And they get,
basically, a handshake.
The truth is, the
degree is bestowed today
by a speech act
of the president,
by authority of the
president and fellows
of Harvard College, and
the members of the board
of overseers, all whom voted
these degrees yesterday.
That is how these
degrees are bestowed.
And they are graduates,
as they are here
in this Tercentenary Theatre.
Then, when they actually
get their diploma,
that's sort of extra.
They didn't really have
diplomas for a long time.
And there's a wonderful piece in
the Harvard Gazette about that
this time, that you
could buy a diploma.
There you see Charles
Rosenberg, Drew Faust's husband
there below the screen.
There's Jeremy
Bloxham on the right,
Jeremy dean of natural sciences.
Area dean for natural sciences
and arts and sciences.
And Lee Rosovsky
on the bottom left.
Lee of course son of the
former dean Rosovsky.
I think I see our next
undergraduate guest, who
is approaching.
Everybody's getting very
excited for this to start.
Welcome.
We have here with us Alex
Diaz, who is at Lowell House.
It's not a wonder that I know
this remarkable young man
as house master.
Lowell House is
already seated, right?
Yes.
We just sat down now.
That's great.
Alex, you know me.
This is Dan Schrag, who is--
Congratulations, Alex.
Thank you so much.
What a great day.
Tell us a little bit about
what you've done here.
Majored in and--
I majored in psychology,
focusing on applying psychology
to law and policy.
And my greatest
passion now is to learn
how to implement policy that's
a little bit more updated
and informed by science,
specifically psychology.
That's wonderful.
So what are you
going to do next?
But your area in
psychology would interest--
Social psychology.
Yes.
Would interest people,
because you're really
examining the roots of--
Unconscious biases, yeah.
--unconscious bias
and prejudice.
That's great.
So tell me, what are
you going to do next?
So I've been blessed enough to
receive a Rhodes Scholarship.
So I'll be at Oxford next year.
That's spectacular.
Reading for public policy
for my first year there.
That'll be a wonderful,
wonderful next step.
I'm so excited.
I cannot wait.
That's really fun.
So when do you head
to the England?
I head in October.
Or last week of September.
That's great.
And what are you going
to do for the summer?
I'll be back home in New Jersey
working with Senator Cory
Booker on his upcoming campaign.
That's very exciting.
Oh, that's terrific.
So tell us a little bit about
your background in Union City
New Jersey.
So, I mean, my parents
immigrated here
from Cuba in the '60s during
the communist revolution,
pulled themselves up
by the bootstraps.
And my dad worked his way
through college and law school,
and worked his way to get
me to be where I am today.
I'm so grateful for my parents
for all they've done for me.
Are they here today with you?
They're here today, yes.
They must be very exciting.
Aw, man.
This is all for them.
It's not even for me.
Do you have brothers
and sisters?
I have two older brothers.
And they're also here, too.
That's great.
What a wonderful celebration.
Good for you.
And what you hope to
be doing in 10 years?
I have no idea.
I want to practice
law for a bit.
But I do want to go back
and help out my community.
Wherever I end up, as long
as I stand for my values,
I feel like I've
accomplished something.
And are you headed to law
school after the Rhodes?
So I'm headed to law
school and business school.
I'll doing the joint
when I come back.
Are you doing that at Harvard?
Yeah, both here.
Oh, good.
So we'll see you again.
I'll be back, yeah.
You'll have a couple
more commencements.
Good for you.
Alex, thank you so much.
Enjoy the rest of the day.
Thank you so much, Diana.
A great pleasure.
Great pleasure to have you here.
Yes, thank you.
OK, we see the final handful
of undergraduates filing in.
Here's one of our honorands.
And I think many people
will recognize him.
Yes, there we go.
President George
H W Bush, 41st--
And he's with Roger Porter
--president of
the United States.
Every honorary
degree recipient is
accompanied by a
Harvard faculty member.
Of course, the
commencement speaker,
the head of the honorary
degree class this year,
is Michael Bloomberg, former
mayor of New York City.
He's accompanied by Rebecca
Henderson, university professor
at the Business School.
Well, at the honorary
degree dinner
last evening, George Bush
was not able to attend.
He's conserving his energy
these days, and rightly so.
But it's a great honor
to have him here.
Honestly, no matter where you
were on the political spectrum
during the Bush years, there
was a lot that happened,
including the fall of the Berlin
Wall, and the end of the Soviet
Union, and--
He also was a huge president.
He achieved a lot.
I think that people
are not aware of some
of his spectacular achievements
in the environment.
For example, the clean
air amendments of 1990
were really under his--
There's another
of our honorands.
People may not recognize him.
That's Seymour Slive.
That is Seymour Slive, they say.
Slive.
But he is a great art historian.
I knew him for conversation at
several Cambridge Scientific
Club, or some of these things
that were really interesting.
It's a wonderful tradition
that every year, at least one
of the honorary
degree recipients
is a former Harvard
faculty member.
Yeah.
And there are a lot of long time
Harvard faculty members who,
well, who already
have degrees, but who
deserve the honor of
an honorary degree.
And we'll see all of
the honorary degree
recipients in just
a little while.
We'll see them one by one.
And everybody who has a
Gazette in their hands
already knows who they are.
A friend of mine,
one of our colleagues
who was on the honorary
degree committee that
selects the honorary
degrees recipients
told me a story-- I don't
know if it's apocryphal--
but that President Bush, when
he was told that he was selected
to receive an honorary
degree from Harvard this year
said, oh, that's wonderful.
Barbara can just drive
me down from Maine.
I don't know if that's
actually how he got here.
I imagine.
That's a wonderful story.
It's only about an
hour from [INAUDIBLE].
Well, the honorary
degrees will be
awarded at the very end of
the festival rites today.
One of the things that I
tore out of the Gazette,
I think it is, is the
accounting of sustainability
that might interest you in
today's commencement program.
That there will be 1,500
pounds of sustainable salmon.
100% of Harvard Yard grounds
are managed organically
with zero toxic
pesticides or herbicides.
There are 109 receptacles for
recycling roundabout here.
A sense that
sustainability is something
that goes from what we eat
to how we manage the grounds.
And certainly, how we
think about the science
of the future.
I mean, this must be
extraordinary for you,
the director of the
Harvard University Center
for the Environment.
Such an important--
I can't help but think
about these issues
when I look out at the class.
Looking at all of these students
from the professional schools,
from the college, these are
the environmental challenges
that they're going to struggle
with for their whole lives.
Yeah.
I mean, this is-- when they
talk about the rising sea level
and what it will be
like in 2050 or 2075,
this is part of the lives
of the people who are here.
We are passing these
challenges onto them.
And in some ways,
you can tell when
you talk to these
students, they're
passionate about these issues.
They're curious.
They want to get out
there and solve them.
They have all
sorts of new ideas.
And I think it's hard not to
feel a little bit optimistic
when you actually
look out and see
all of these smart students
heading off to the world
and try to make
it a better place.
There's Richard Tarrant, has a
very important role in Harvard
commencement.
He is the person who is in
charge of the committee that
selects the student
commencement speakers,
and that coaches
them as they practice
to deliver their address
before such a huge
and in many ways very,
very intimidating crowd.
And if you ask who is speaking
at Harvard commencement,
well, the speakers here are
literally three students--
two undergraduates and
a graduate student.
And then of course,
this afternoon, people
will acknowledge that
there is the speech
of former mayor of New
York Mayor Bloomberg.
But the speakers are
basically students here.
A Latin address and
two English addresses.
That's right.
So there's some relatively
short addresses by students.
And the rest of it is
really just the ceremony.
It happens very, very quickly.
Really, once it starts, it'll
be over in about an hour
and a half.
But there are a lot of students
to acknowledge in the meantime.
Many of the people who are
interested in the speakers
at the Harvard
commencement in general
also are interested in who is
speaking at the class days.
We mentioned Sheryl
Sandberg, the CEO of Facebook
who spoke yesterday
to the undergraduates.
At the Kennedy
School, the class day
speaker with Samantha
Power, who is currently
our ambassador to
the United Nations.
That's right.
Samantha ran the Carr
Center for Human Rights
here at the Kennedy
School for many years.
She's a spectacular
journalist and author,
wrote that beautiful
book on a history
of American foreign policy
dealing with genocide.
Yes.
Lessons from Hell.
Problem from Hell, yes.
And really has been
very influential
on the National Security Council
in the Obama administration
before she was appointed to the
ambassador position to the UN.
At the School of Public Health--
or I think maybe at the Medical
School rather-- Vivek Murthy,
also a Harvard graduate
who was the nominee
for Surgeon General,
was the class day speaker.
And each of the
schools-- Law School,
Public Health-- have
their own speakers
for the in gathering
of the class
on the day before commencement.
But Samantha Power
is a classic example
of someone who really very
common at Harvard how many
of our colleagues, both on the
faculty and former students,
who go onto service.
Who really focus on
serving this nation
and serving the world in
a variety of capacities.
Today, we say goodbye
to a colleague of ours
in the law school, David Barron.
David and I taught
a course together.
He focuses on a variety
of issues in cities.
And we taught a
course together on how
Boston will deal with sea
level rise, along with a couple
of professors from the
Graduate School of Design.
And what about the river houses?
Are they still
going to be there?
They will still be there.
I'm a little more
worried about Austin.
But David Barron.
Served in the early days
of the Obama administration
in the Legal Counsel office.
And then he's now
just been nominated
to become a judge on
the circuit court.
He was just confirmed
a few days ago.
And so he will be leaving
Harvard tomorrow, on Friday,
and take up his
judgeship in Boston.
It's both bittersweet.
It's wonderful that
he will be there.
We need his kind of wise
counsel on the bench.
But at same time, we'll miss him
from being part of our faculty.
We remember today, of course,
that you were reminding me
as we gather that
this is actually
the birthday of John F Kennedy.
That's right.
He would be 97 if
he were alive today.
When I think of the
50th reunion class,
I mean, this has been
from start to finish
a year of 50th commemorations.
And that 50th reunion class
lived through them all, really,
from the beginning of
their senior year on.
There was the 50th anniversary
of the March on Washington.
Then the 50th anniversary
and commemoration
of the assassination
of President Kennedy.
Yeah.
In fact, if you talk to
the 50th reunion class,
I've spoken to many of them.
They all know exactly where
they were at that time
when they heard that news.
And then the 50th
anniversary of that spring,
when students went down to
lobby for the civil rights bill.
And the 50th anniversary
of the visit of the Beatles
to Cambridge.
I mean, all of this was
part of the lived life
of that remarkable class.
And it includes, by the way, you
mentioned Sheila Jasanoff and--
Marshal Ganz.
--Marshal Gantz.
Stephen Breyer, a
Supreme Court Justice.
And Andy Weil, one of the
great health gurus of our time
all back for this 50th reunion.
And we wish them well.
I have one personal interest
in this Extension School class
that's graduating.
And that is my to
be daughter-in-law
is getting a degree in
extension studies as a graduate
with a Master's in
Museum Studies today.
Diana, congratulations.
That's wonderful.
Good for her.
What is her name?
Her name is Crystal Stone.
And her fiance,
Kreshnik Zejnullahu
is one of the four
kids from Kosovo
who came to live
with us in 1999.
And he will graduate from
medical school in UMass
on Sunday.
And then the two of them
will get married a week
from Saturday in
Lowell House, and then
head off for his residency
at University of California
at San Francisco.
So it's really fun.
It's wonderful.
And of course, the Extension
School is often forgotten,
but it's a very important
part of Harvard.
It is.
The way that we
reach so many people
who have a variety of
alternative education
opportunities.
It's open.
It's our Open University.
And it really is
very, very important.
So many people are connected
to this proceeding today.
I was at the doctor yesterday.
I went to see an eye
doctor yesterday.
I don't need glasses.
I'm fine.
But I was telling-- he
asked me what I did.
And I told him I was
a professor and was
going to be doing the
commencement today.
He told me about
his niece, who's
graduating from the Medical
School, Catherine Eric
Kohn, who's part of the
Medical School class today.
Oh, there you see
Mayor Bloomberg.
Mayor Bloomberg with
one of our honorands.
Very special woman.
Aretha Franklin.
This is going to be really a
very exciting, very exciting
commencement morning.
Everyone does have
their memories.
And you talk about
your eye doctor.
I was running across the street
and hailed by a former class
day speaker, or commencement
speaker, the comedian Jimmy
Tingle, who was with us
a couple of years ago.
I do think most
everyone is seated.
I don't see those
rows of empty chairs.
I think when we see the
marshals come down the aisle
and report to the
university marshal
that everyone is seated.
I still see a handful
of students filing in.
There they are.
But they're almost done.
You can see the end of
the procession there.
The band playing
10,000 Men of Harvard.
And certainly today, there
are 20,000 men and women
of Harvard gathered here in
the Tercentenary Theatre.
It is just extraordinary
to see this space so filled
with such a gala
array of people.
There's Dean Pfister, who
has served so admirably
as the interim dean
of the college.
Talking to Jackie
O'Neill, the marshal.
And she's about
ready to get going.
Martha Minow just
walked by the camera,
the dean of the Law School.
And Julio Frenk is
looking at us there
in his blue and gold robes.
And in the white is--
Former health minister
of Mexico, and now dean
of the School of Public Health.
In the white is Grace Scheibner,
who deserves a lot of credit
for putting this
whole show together.
She has an office over
in Wadsworth House
and works on this from one
commencement to another.
Yes.
Planning for this event does
not happen in just a few weeks.
This is something that
really takes all year long.
There's Jackie O'Neill.
This is the oldest
non-religious ritual
in the United
States, the festival
rites of Harvard commencement.
And this sense of the
gathering of a great university
is really powerful,
of the faculties,
of the students,
and of the alumnae,
who constitute part of what
is now embraced in that term--
Harvard University.
Here come the marshals, the
last few people to file in.
Let's see them with
their top hats.
The array of marshals
responsible for keeping order
as the ushers and sort of ritual
magistrates of the university.
It's kind of remarkable that
this isn't just total chaos.
It is incredible that
this is not total chaos.
And that is due to the good
offices of the marshals.
Everybody's getting ready.
I can sense the anticipation
of the students.
The last few people
are filing in now.
There they are.
Ben Levy reporting, Harry Lewis
reporting to Jackie O'Neill
that all is in order.
[BELL RINGS]
The bell is rung.
[CHEERING]
A roar goes up from this crowd.
Mr. Sheriff, pray,
give us order.
As the high sheriff
of Middlesex County,
I declare that the
meeting will be in order.
[CHEERING]
Please rise as our honorand
Miss Aretha Franklin performs--
[CHEERING]
--performs the national anthem--
--after which the
chaplain of the day
will deliver the opening prayer.
Oh say can you see by the dawn's
early light, what so proudly
we hailed at the twilight's
last gleaming, whose
broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous night o'er
the ramparts we watched
were so gallantly streaming.
And the rockets' red glare,
the bombs bursting in air,
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there.
[CHEERING]
Oh say does that star
spangled banner yet
wave, o'er the land of
the free and the home-- we
are the home of the brave.
[APPLAUSE]
The home of the brave.
Look to the soaring heavens.
Look to the depths
of our hearts.
And let us pray that
from horizon to horizon,
from the first glimmering of
an idea to its full flowering,
from the dawning
of companionship
to firm friendship and
fellowship in learning,
all we celebrate
today be blessed.
May the world find blessing in
the women and men of Harvard.
May these bannered hosts
arrayed in crimson fledge
as forces for good in
the world of our times,
so that speedily and soon,
on the hill of Washington
and in the canyons
of Wall Street,
in the highest
reaches of academe,
and on the vanguard's of
our arts and industry,
in schools and in hospitals, in
laboratories and in law firms,
in theaters of conflict, and
in crucibles of statecraft,
there may be heard new
voices of wisdom and voices
of compassion, voices of
reason and voices of insight,
voices of exhilaration and
voices of understanding.
Voices that say,
let us join hands
to forge a way of purpose and of
promise, for the need is great,
and the time has come.
For just as the rain and the
snow fall from the heavens
and there do not return
without first having watered
the Earth so that she births,
and sprouts, and gives seed
to the one who sows and
bread to the one who eats,
so too shall be my word which
proceedeth from my mouth.
It shall not return to me
unfulfilled, nor without first
having accomplished that which
I desire, and having prospered,
that for which I send it.
You shall go forth in joy
and be guided by peace.
The mountains and the hills will
give a joyous shout before you,
and all the trees of
the field will applaud.
So may it be with us this
glorious day and every day.
And if such can be your prayer
today, then say with me amen.
Amen.
[SINGING IN LATIN]
Latin salutatory.
[SPEAKING LATIN]
Did I get that right?
Candidate for the
degree of bachelor
of arts, Timothy
Barry-Heffernan.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING LATIN]
Senior English address, a
Harvard spring candidate
for the degree of bachelor
of arts, Sarah Abushaar.
When I was around seven,
my toothless brother
and I on long, boring
taxi rides in Syria
would indulge in
imperialistic fantasies
of how we wanted to
take over the country
outside our windows.
My parents would quickly
crush these imperial conquests
by warning, shh, you'll get
taking by Secret Service
if they hear you.
The walls everywhere,
we were told,
could hear our
revolutionary ideas
and would send us to prison.
Whereas children here had
ghosts and the bogey man,
our equivalents our governments.
Fast forward to 2010.
When I first got
here, someone told me
if Harvard shut its gates, it
could be its own country, just
like the Vatican.
As I've walked through
this place every day
for the past four
years, I was struck
by how true this idea was.
I thought everywhere
the Harvard nation.
I saw it in the big
and obvious things.
We had our own version of the
Statue of Liberty-- the John
Harvard statue.
Our own embassies, the Harvard
clubs of Boston and London.
A tax collection agency, the
Harvard Alumni Association.
[LAUGHTER]
And an endowment larger than
more than half the world's
countries GDPs.
We also have our own
diplomatic passports.
Nowhere did I see this
more clearly than at US
immigration at
Boston Logan Airport.
Whenever they saw I was
coming from the Middle
East-- what were
you doing there.
Why are you here?
Why did God make you
from the Middle East?
But I made sure I dressed like
our overly proud Harvard dads
with Harvard hat, Harvard shirt,
Harvard shorts, and Harvard
underwear.
And as soon as they saw I
was a citizen of Harvard,
oh, you go to Harvard.
Surely you must not be a
national security threat.
Welcome to America.
And suddenly, all the gates to
the American dream opened wide.
I saw it everywhere,
this Harvard nation,
but I saw it not just
in the hard structures.
But more importantly, in
its invisible institutions.
The invisible scaffolds
around and under-girding
the hard institutions.
I saw it in the quarreling
columns of the Crimson
newspaper, it's kung fu fights
of ideas and lively student
debates with the potency
to propel policy changes
by the next morning's print.
I saw it in our cluttered
bulletin boards, bustling
with life, with announcements
of student led conferences,
Broadway worthy shows,
and dorm room projects
turned world's next Facebook
smothering each other
for our cursory glimpse.
A trivial detail,
these cluttered boards
that often slip notice.
But where some saw papers, I saw
passions, purpose, creativity.
I saw a heartbeat of civic
community's vivacity.
My parents'
countries were places
where institutional
dysfunction killed off
the social dynamism and
vibrant productivity.
And so I felt acutely
here the value
of civil society and living,
breathing institutions.
My time here would
give me a working model
of a better world.
Not only that, but that sense of
empowerment to initiate change.
You see, with those
spying walls still lurking
in my memory that constrained
the little Napoleons
in my brother and me, you
might imagine my shock
when in one of my
first classes here,
I suddenly found myself
debating a president.
So it's the 1990s.
Our negotiations class
professor set the stage.
A war is about to break out
between Ecuador and Peru.
How will you stop it?
I raised my hand to respond.
Wait.
Professor Shapiro stopped me.
Tell the president what to do.
And in walked the
Ecuadorian president.
And bringing the
president to me and having
me speak to and question
a shaper of history
and experience the
value he saw in my view,
Harvard would make me
feel I too could be him.
I too had the power to
shape history and not
just be passively shaped by it.
That sense of
infinite possibility
we have as children to think
big and conquer great things
was returned to me here.
A less despotic version of it.
But what seemed intractable
problems of the world
became opportunities for
me, for us to change things.
You know, when I first got
here, my name was Sarah.
After Harvard, it
would become, hey
Harvard, with people
stuffing 378 years,
5,000 acres of real estate, the
entirety of Widener Library,
and 32 heads of state all into
my five foot six inch self.
Ridiculous as it is, there's
a strange reality to it.
Arab American
author Randa Jarrar
pictures inhabiting a new
place as running barefoot,
the skin of our
feet collecting sand
and seeds and rocks and
grass until we had shoes,
shoes made of everything
we picked up as we ran.
And running through Harvard
Yard over the past four years,
the skin of our feet collecting
a world of experiences,
we each become this
place in a strange way.
Each of us picking up bits of
people, and history, and ideas
that changed the way
we saw the world.
Accumulations I hope we will
continue to wear on our souls
and leave a footprint of all the
best we took from Harvard Yard
on our new destinations.
And that's why I am
hopeful for the future.
I'm hopeful because of
my dining hall dinners
spent marveling at friends who,
while their countries waged
bloody war against each
other, are able to carry out
civil conversation and build
generative projects together.
I am hopeful because
of the founding mothers
and founding fathers of
revolutionary ideas like these
being launched
into the world, who
will make of its institutions,
its constitutions,
its hospitals, its art
houses something better.
We hear a lot in the news
about an Arab Spring.
This graduation is
sending 6,000 revolutions
into the world in the 6,000
revolutions graduating
as part of the class of 2014.
If we take those revolutions,
those great ideas
sparked behind Chipotle
burritos and Starbucks coffee
cups in our version of Tahrir
Square, Harvard Square,
out with us into the real world,
into the real Tahrir Squares,
and make something of them.
Revolution's not in
arms, but in minds
more powerful, and
permanent, and pervasive.
For this isn't a Ukrainian
revolution or an Arab Spring,
but a global revolution.
This is the Harvard
spring of 2014.
This is the Harvard Spring.
[APPLAUSE]
Graduate English address,
A Kind of Destiny.
Candidate for the
degree of Master
in Public Policy,
Philip A Harding.
Over two centuries
ago, a man came
to Harvard uncertain of
his future and his fate.
He had received an offer
he could not refuse,
and though he felt unworthy,
he wrote to his family
that he believed
a kind of destiny
was driving him to Cambridge.
He spent his first night right
here sleeping in Harvard Yard,
and awoke the next
morning-- July 3, 1775--
to take command of the troops
of the United Provinces of North
America, the fledgling
Continental Army.
George Washington had a unique
Harvard application process.
His admissions committee was
the Second Continental Congress.
And his experience
here at Harvard
would not only define the
final 24 years of his life,
but the startup he
launched here would go on
to change the course
of human history.
Just across the street, under a
tree, is a group of monuments,
one displaying rows of
strapping uniformed soldiers
welcoming Washington
to Cambridge.
And another says,
under this tree,
Washington first took command
of the American army--
July 3, 1775.
And I've always
felt a sense of awe
for this world changing spot.
But then I did some
research, and I
found something less romantic.
Washington's Harvard welcome
weekend was less than grand,
and his first year Harvard
was downright awful.
On Sunday, July 2, he
rode in to a deserted
looking town soaking
wet and half sick.
In fact, the welcome reception
was canceled due to rain.
And several soldiers
wrote in their journals
that nothing new or remarkable
happened on July 3rd.
Imagine if we could go back in
time to this very spot that day
in 1775.
We would be sitting in
a very different Harvard
Yard, a field full of makeshift
tents, un-uniformed soldiers,
and a rough defense position
in place of Lamont Library.
One historian
described this scene
like Woodstock, New York 1969.
A volunteer undisciplined,
under-equipped militia
of farmers and merchants.
This was the group,
about half the size
of the crowd we've
assembled this morning,
this was the group
that Washington
came to lead against the
most powerful military force
on Earth.
But Washington took what was
offered to him here at Harvard
and he made the most of it.
And I'm not just
talking about the brass
doorknobs, or the metal roof
he took off Harvard hall
to melt into musket balls--
which they did take.
But he took ideas that existed
only as words and writings
and he turned them into reality
for millions and generations
to come.
And less than a year later,
after pushing the British out
of Boston, Washington
received an honorary degree
from this fine institution,
his first academic degree.
And like many
Harvard graduates, he
went on to take a prominent
position in New York City.
And it almost killed him.
Well, the British
nearly killed him.
And we almost lost
the entire war.
In fact, the next seven
years of the war effort
would become the most
challenging years of his life.
Today, you will receive a
piece of paper representing
your short time here at Harvard.
Your successes, your failures,
your all night study sessions,
your lessons, your
first A minus.
And the friendships that
will last a lifetime.
Through these
experiences, you've
developed, practiced, and
honed the skills you need.
But sitting here today, facing
an uncertain future-- let alone
the examples of mayors and
entrepreneurs, Nobel Prize
winners, presidents,
and a queen,
the queen of soul--
sitting here today
facing a lot of uncertainty
and a lot of high bars,
it might seem
difficult to connect
the dots to your destiny.
But have faith.
Because there is a kind of
destiny waiting to be fulfilled
that is uniquely yours.
You see, Washington had
to go through a difficult
transformation process, even
after receiving his Harvard
degree, to turn
his kind of destiny
into a real force that
could change history.
And he came to discover
he could not do it alone.
The individuals
and incidents that
faced him over the
next seven years
whittled, carved,
and sculpted him
into the monumental
man we remember today.
And in the end,
the army he thought
he was coming to
transform ended up
being the force that
transformed him.
And while you may
not realize it yet,
some of the biggest
lessons you'll
take with you from
this experience
have come from the people who've
been learning right beside you.
They've challenged you.
They've pushed you.
They've inspired you.
They've supported
you, and ultimately
helped reveal a better
version of yourself.
You see, the
question is not only
what you will take with you,
but who you will take with you.
On July 4, 1775, still a full
year before the Declaration
of Independence, Washington
issued his first general orders
to the troops from right
here in Harvard Yard,
declaring that all
distinctions of colonies
should be laid aside so that one
spirit may animate the whole,
and the only contest
be who shall render,
on this great and trying
occasion, the most
essential service to this
great and common cause
in which we are all engaged.
And just as Washington
came here to Harvard
to unite the 13 colonies, we've
come together this morning
to celebrate the unity and
diversity of our 13 schools.
Whether you are driven to
solve the world's largest
public or private problems,
cure that dreaded disease,
alleviate human suffering, work
across religious and cultural
divides, generate knowledge
and push education forward.
[CHEERING]
Create effective
legal frameworks.
[CHEERING]
Design and construct the
future world we live in.
[CHEERING]
Or use technology to enable new
discoveries and innovations.
[CHEERING]
Whatever kind of destiny
is compelling you today,
imagine the countless lives that
are waiting for you to step up.
In two centuries, who might be
talking about the grand mission
you begin today in this yard?
Who will be saying
they sat right there
under that tree in that spot?
Let today be your moment to
accept the challenge that
has been offered to you.
Bring that most
essential service only
you can provide to this
great and common cause.
And together, let us not
just go change the world,
but let us go serve
the world with passion.
[APPLAUSE]
[SINGING LATIN]
These addresses by selected
candidates for ordinary degrees
being ended, the deans of
the several departments
will now present to the
president and fellows
and to the board of overseers
in the favoring presence
of the friends here assembled,
the candidates on whom
the various academic
distinctions are,
with due ceremony,
to be conferred.
The dean of the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, members of
the board of overseers.
Mr. President.
In the name of the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences,
and by its authority,
I have the honor
to report on four
groups of candidates
who will be presented
to you today.
First, the dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences
will present candidates for the
degree of Doctor of Philosophy,
and then the degrees of
Master of Arts and of Science.
Next, the dean of the School
of Engineering and Applied
Sciences will present candidates
for the degrees of Master
of Science and of Engineering.
Third, the dean of Continuing
Education and University
Extension will
present candidates
for the degrees of Associates in
Arts, Bachelor of Liberal Arts,
and Master of Liberal
Arts in Extension Studies.
Finally, near the close
of these exercises,
the seniors in
Harvard College who
are candidates for the first
degree in arts or in science
will stand proudly before you.
The candidates in
each of these groups
have, by vote of the
faculty, fulfilled
the requirements for the degrees
for which they are severally
recommended.
I salute all these
men and women,
trusting that they will forever
wisely enjoy the freedoms
that their education has
given to them while bearing
the responsibilities that
their learning demands of them.
Each of these groups will
now be introduced to you
by the deans responsible for
the programs in which they
had been enrolled.
Candidates for the degree of
Doctor of Philosophy will rise.
The dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences.
Madame President, fellows of
Harvard College, Mr. President,
members of board of
overseers, and Mr. President.
As dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences,
I have the honor to present to
you these scholars, all of whom
have devoted themselves
to rigorous pursuit
of advanced study, have
attained high distinction,
and have made original
contributions to knowledge
in their several
fields of scholarships.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
and recognizing your high
academic achievements,
I confer on you women
and men of learning
the degree of Doctor
of Philosophy.
And I welcome you to the
ancient and universal company
of scholars and entrust
to you the free inquiry
of future generations.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates from
the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences for
the degrees of Master
of Arts and Master
of Science will rise.
The dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, members of board
of overseers, Mr. President.
As dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences,
I have the honor to present
to you these candidates,
all of whom have completed
a commemorable step
of advanced study in their
respective disciplines.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree
of Master of Arts or Master
of Science, and certify
that you have surmounted
with distinction the first
stage of graduate study.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates from the School
of Engineering and Applied
Sciences for the degrees of
Master of Science and Master
of Engineering will rise.
The dean of the School of
Engineering and Applied
Sciences.
Madame President, fellows of
Harvard College, Mr. President,
board of overseers,
and Mr. President,
as dean of the School of
Engineering and Applied
Sciences, I have the honor
to present to you these women
and men who have completed their
first step of advanced study
in engineering and
applied sciences.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree of
Master of Science or Master
of Engineering and certify
that you have surmounted
with distinction the first
stage of graduate study.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the degrees
of Associate in Arts,
Bachelor of Liberal
Arts, and Master
of Liberal Arts in
Extension Studies will rise.
The dean of Continuing Education
and University Extension.
Madame President, fellows of
Harvard College, Mr. President.
Hat back on here.
[LAUGHTER]
And members of the
board of overseers.
As the dean of the division of
Continuing Ed and University
Extension, I have the
honor to present to you
these students, candidates
for the degrees of Associates
of Arts, and Bachelor
of Liberal Arts,
and Master of Liberal
Arts in Extension Studies.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree
of Associate in Arts,
Bachelor of Liberal
Arts, or Master
of Liberal Arts in
extension studies,
and admit you to the fellowship
of educated men and women.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
[BAND PLAYING]
[SINGING LATIN]
[APPLAUSE]
The dean of the
Faculty of Medicine.
[APPLAUSE]
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, members of
the board of overseers.
And Mr. President.
In the name of the Faculty of
Medicine and by its authority,
I have the honor to report today
that two groups of candidates
in the fields of medicine
and dental medicine
have fulfilled the requirements
of the faculty for the degrees
for which they are recommended.
They will be introduced
to you by the deans
responsible for the programs
in which they are enrolled.
The candidates for the degrees
of Doctor of Dental Medicine,
Doctor of Medical Sciences,
and Master of Medical Sciences
will rise.
The dean of the School
of Dental Medicine.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, and members
of the board of overseers.
Mr. President.
As dean of the School
of Dental Medicine,
I have the honor to present to
you these women and men, each
of whom has devoted four years
to the study of medicine,
or at least three years to
post doctoral studies aimed
at improving health and
the quality of life.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree
of Doctor of Dental Medicine,
Doctor of Medical Sciences,
or Master of Medical Sciences,
and declare that
you are qualified
for practice and research in a
demanding branch of medicine.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the degrees of
Doctor of Medicine and Master
of Medical Science will rise.
[CHEERING]
The dean for Medical Education.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, and
members of the board
of overseers, Mr. President,
Mr. Mayor, and madame queen.
As dean for Medical
Education, I have the honor
to present to you these
men and women, each of whom
has worked hard and well to
prepare for a life of learning
and service in medicine.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree of
Doctor of Medicine or Master
of Medical Science and declare
that as physicians, you
are ready to engage in an
honorable and merciful calling.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the degree of
Master of Theological Studies,
Master of Divinity,
a Master of Theology,
and Doctor of
Theology will rise.
[CHEERING]
The dean of the
faculty of Divinity.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, members of
the board of overseers,
Mr. President.
As dean of the
Faculty of Divinity,
I have the honor to present to
you these women and men, each
of whom has devoted two,
three, or more years
to theological or
religious studies,
in preparation for
careers as leaders,
in scholarship and
vocations of service.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree of
Master of Theological Studies,
Master of Divinity, Master of
Theology, or Doctor of Theology
and declare that you are well
prepared to foster the health
and vitality of
communities of faith,
and to further scholarship
in religious studies,
and to help in shaping the
shared values of the broader
society.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the degrees of
Doctor of Law, Master of Laws,
and Doctor of Juridical
Science will rise.
[CHEERING]
The Dean of the Faculty of Law.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, members of
the board of overseers,
Mr. President Mr.
Mayor, queen of soul,
distinguished honorands.
As dean of the Faculty
of Law, I have the honor
to present to you these
women and men, each of whom
has completed a degree
in Legal Studies
toward the end of advancing
justice and promoting
the rule of law.
[CHEERING]
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree of
Doctor of Law, Master of Laws,
or Doctor of Juridical
Science and declare
that you are ready to aid in
the shaping and application
of those wise restraints
that make us free.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the
degrees of Master
in Business Administration--
[CHEERING]
--and Doctor of Business
Administration will rise.
The dean of the Faculty of
Business Administration.
[CHEERING]
Madame President, fellows of
Harvard College, Mr. President,
members of the board of
overseers, and Mr. President,
and Mr. Mayor.
As dean of the Faculty of
Business Administration,
it is my great honor to present
to you these women and men who
have mastered the study
of Business Administration
and prepared themselves
to become leaders who
will make a difference
in the world.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the
degree of Master
in Business
Administration or Doctor
of Business Administration
and testified
that you are ready to lead
people, and organizations,
and enterprises that will make
a difference in the world.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the several
degrees in architecture,
landscape architecture, urban
planning, and design will rise.
The dean of the
Faculty of Design.
[APPLAUSE]
Madame President, fellows of
Harvard College, Mr. President,
and members of the
board of overseers,
as the dean of the
Faculty of Design,
I have the honor to present to
you these men and women, each
of whom has qualified
for a Master's
degree in Architecture,
Landscape Architecture, Urban
Design, Urban Planning,
or Design Studies,
or for the degree
of Doctor of Design.
By virtue of authority
designated to me,
I confer on each
of you the degree
for which you have qualified
and declare your competence
to lead in shaping the
spaces in which we live.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the degrees
of Doctor of Education--
[APPLAUSE]
--Doctor of
Education Leadership,
and Master of
Education will rise.
[APPLAUSE]
The dean of the
Faculty of Education.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, members of
the board of overseers,
Mr. President.
As dean of the
Faculty of Education,
I have the honor to present
to you these women and men--
[CHEERING]
--who will be leaders--
--in education practice,
policy, and research.
[CHEERING]
By virtue of authority delegated
to me, I confer on each of you
the Master's or Doctor's
degree in Education
and declare that you are well
prepared to guide and serve
the learning needs of
contemporary society.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the several
degrees in Public Health
will rise.
[CHEERING]
The dean of the Faculty
of Public Health.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President, and members
of the board of overseers.
As dean of the faculty
of Public Health,
now in its 100th
anniversary, I have the honor
to present to you these
women and men, each of whom
has qualified for a Master's
degree or a Doctoral
degree to provide leadership,
advanced knowledge,
and improve the public's health.
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the
degrees in public health
for which your studies
have qualified you,
and I declare that you are
well prepared to generate
and utilize knowledge to improve
health throughout the world.
Congratulations.
Candidates for the
degrees of Master
in Public Administration--
[CHEERING]
--Master in Public
Administration in International
Development--
[CHEERING]
--and Master in Public Policy--
--will rise.
The dean of the
Faculty of Government.
Madame President, fellows
of Harvard College,
Mr. President,
members of the board
of overseers, Mr.
President, Mr. Mayor,
and royally deserving
distinguished honorands.
As dean of the Faculty
of Government, it is my--
[CHEERING]
It is my great honor to present
to you these women and men,
each of whom have
qualified to provide
outstanding leadership
in public service.
[CHEERING]
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the degree
for which your studies have
qualified you, and
testify that you are well
prepared to offer
leadership in the quest
for enlightened public policy
and effective public service
throughout the world.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
[BAND PLAYING]
[SINGING LATIN]
[APPLAUSE]
Candidates for the degree of
Bachelor of Arts or of Science
will rise.
[CHEERING]
Their chosen
representatives together
with candidates for those
degrees summa cum laude
will draw near.
With warm appreciation for
his leadership and service
this past year, I
recognize the interim dean
of Harvard College.
[CHEERING]
[CHANTING]
Pfister, Pfister, Pfister,
Pfister, Pfister.
Madame President.
fellows of Harvard
College, Mr. President,
members of the
board of overseers.
As dean of Harvard
College, it is my--
[CHEERING]
I have the honor to present to
you these women and men, each
of whom have fulfilled--
I'm emotional.
They--
[CHEERING]
[CHANTING]
Pfister, Pfister, Pfister,
Pfister, Pfister, Pfister.
Each of whom has fulfilled
the faculty's requirements
for the first degree
in Arts and Sciences.
Each candidate stands
before you prepared
to advance knowledge,
promote understanding,
and to serve society.
[CHEERING]
By virtue of authority
delegated to me,
I confer on you the first
degree in Arts or in Sciences
and admit you to the fellowship
of educated men and women.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHANTING]
OK, my turn now.
No one, it has been
said of our first guest,
has done more to kindle
a passion for the arts
at Harvard.
He joined the Harvard
faculty 60 years ago,
a World War II Navy
veteran with two degrees
from the University of Chicago.
He went on to become a
preeminent art historian,
a museum leader, and a teacher
of uncommon prowess and flair.
He has shaped the
study of Dutch art,
especially the golden
age works of Rembrandt
and other Dutch masters.
His famed lectures captivated
thousands of Harvard students,
spellbinding talks,
one student recalls,
that open both your
eyes and your heart.
For nearly a decade,
he served with aplomb
as director of the
Fogg Art Museum,
strengthening one of Harvard's
most treasured institutions
and propelling plans
for the Sackler Museum.
In one admirer's
words, he is a credit
to humanity in every way as
a scholar, family man, friend
to many, generous in spirit,
and scrupulous in his dealings
with everyone.
When friends set out
to produce a volume
to commemorate his
75th birthday in 1995,
they attracted nearly as many
eager contributors as the years
it marked.
He has personified the
university's commitment
to understanding and
preserving culture at a time
when the arts and humanities
more than ever demand
and deserve our support.
As a colleague writes, for
generations of students,
he was art history at Harvard.
Another said simply this-- he is
the only man at Harvard I ever
loved.
We proudly honor Harvard's
own Gleason Professor
of Fine Arts Emeritus,
Seymour Slive.
[APPLAUSE]
A living portrait in
ebullient erudition and humane
inspiration, he has
masterfully illumined the works
of Dutch masters, his own
career a rare work of art.
Seymour Slive, Doctor of Arts.
[APPLAUSE]
Our next guest
has been a pioneer
at the crossroads of law,
medicine, ethics, and policy,
and she has been an
exemplar of academic values
and common sense in the
governance of the university.
After a childhood in
the segregated south,
she came to Massachusetts
to attend Wheaton College.
She went on to Harvard
Law School in an era
when the doors of legal
education and practice
had barely begun to open
for African American women.
She pursued her
devotion to civil rights
in positions at the Equal
Employment Opportunity
Commission and the
Department of Justice
before launching a four decade
career at the Georgetown
University Law Center.
Having served on a
landmark commission
on protecting human subjects
of biomedical research,
she played a formative role in
shaping the field of bioethics.
Over the years, she has applied
her expertise and judgment
to complex ethical questions
posed by everything
from human radiation
experiments to genomics,
from stem cell research to
the interplay of bioethics
and race.
At Harvard, she brought
her strong moral compass,
her multi-disciplinary
outlook, and her deep concern
for educational opportunity to
bear on the work of the Harvard
Corporation from
2006 until 2012.
She has also played
leadership roles
on the boards of Wheaton
College, the Russell Sage
Foundation, and the
Kaiser Family Foundation,
besides serving on
major advisory counsels
for the National
Institutes of Health,
the Institute of
Medicine, and others.
She wears her prodigious
accomplishments
with humility and grace.
We have all been the fortunate
beneficiaries of her wisdom.
We proudly honor our colleague
and friend Patricia King.
[APPLAUSE]
Bridging disciplines
and overcoming barriers,
elucidating ethics, and
embracing beneficence,
a trusted trustee whose
sagacity and tenacity
always bend the arc
towards justice,
Patricia N King, Doctor of Laws.
[APPLAUSE]
As a student, he was struck by
the incongruities he perceived
between the standard models
taught in economics class
and the realities he
witnessed in daily life.
He began to question
the invisible hand
and to wonder about
the limits of markets.
In time, he rose to
prominence in an array
of domains of economics--
macroeconomics
and monetary theory,
development economics and trade,
and the distribution of income
and wealth, to name a few.
Among his academic
colleagues, he
is perhaps best
recognized for shaping
the economics of
information, in particular
for explaining how uneven
access to information
affects the
operation of markets.
His work earned him a
Nobel Prize in 2001.
His noted books
for wider audiences
include Globalization
and its Discontents
and The Price of Inequality.
They reflect his concern for
how and when governments should
intervene in markets,
and how efforts
to spur the global
economy might be
devised to lessen rather
than widen the growing
gap between rich and poor.
He served at MIT, Yale,
Stanford, Oxford, and Princeton
before becoming a
university professor
at Columbia, where he founded
the initiative for policy
dialogue and co-chairs the
Committee on Global Thought.
Deeply engaged with national and
international economic policy,
he has also serve as chairman
of the President's Council
of Economic Advisers, chief
economist of the World Bank,
and chair of the UN commission
on reforming the International
Monetary and Financial System.
We recognize the eminent
economist Joseph Stiglitz.
[APPLAUSE]
Demarking the limits of markets,
discerning global discontents,
a paramount progenitor
of information economics
who bestrides the spheres
of theory and policy,
Joseph E Stiglitz,
Doctor of Laws.
[APPLAUSE]
He is one of the world's
great plant biologists
and a champion of
global biodiversity.
As one colleague put it, he
is a dynamo intellectually
with a passion for science, for
nature, and for conservation
with a good dose
of fun mixed in.
Time Magazine hailed him
as a hero for the planet.
His many honors include the
National Medal of Science.
He long led the renowned
Missouri Botanical Garden while
serving as Angelman
Professor of Biology
at Washington
University in St. Louis.
A prolific researcher, he
helped introduce co-evolution,
a seminal concept in
evolutionary biology.
He has also made
fundamental contributions
in biogeography, folk taxonomy,
and pollution studies.
A distinguished teacher, he
has written leading textbooks
on both botany and
the environment
and mentored scores
of grateful students.
An energetic citizen
of science, he
has been a central figure in
the work of both the National
Academy of Sciences and the
National Geographic Society.
Recognized worldwide for his
leadership in conservation
and sustainability, he has been
elected to scientific academies
in nearly 20 nations, from
Denmark to New Zealand,
from Brazil to India.
He helped lead a massive
project to classify the 31,500
species of plants
in China and has
been a catalyst for
international scientific
collaboration.
We salute a man who in
the words of one admirer
has touched the whole world
with the power of science
and the moral imperative of the
conservation of life-- Peter
Raven.
[APPLAUSE]
A grand sycamore in
the garden of science,
he has nourished our knowledge
of the phyla of flora
and cultivated care for the
precious diversity of life--
Peter Hamilton Raven,
Doctor of Science.
[APPLAUSE]
Maybe the most important
reason for writing
is to prevent the
erosion of time
so that memories will not
be blown away by the wind,
our next guest has said.
We should write what
should not be forgotten.
Her own vivid works of
imagination and remembrance
will not be forgotten
by countless readers
around the world.
Born in Peru, raised
largely in Chile,
she had a turbulent childhood.
In time, she made her way as a
journalist and talk show host
in Santiago.
On September 11,
1973, a violent coup
felled President Salvador
Allende, her cousin.
Suddenly everything changed.
By 1975, she was in exile in
Venezuela building a new life.
In 1981, she learned that
her beloved grandfather,
still living in
Chile, was dying.
The letter she set
out to write him
grew into her first novel,
The House of the Spirits,
a landmark in Latin American
fiction and a testament
to Chile's tumultuous times.
She has gone on to
write 20 books in all,
emerging as one of the Western
hemisphere's most illustrious
authors.
Her stories mix
history with fantasy,
the intensely political
with the fiercely personal,
the strikingly real with
the hauntingly surreal.
Her several memoirs reflect
with candor and wonder
on her own life experience,
including the devastating death
of her daughter
Paula, in whose memory
she maintains a
charitable foundation
to promote the welfare of
women and children worldwide.
Her lyrical style has
been described as packed
with action, prodigal
in invention,
vivid in description
and metaphor.
Her stories, as
one critic writes,
have moved the readers of
Latin American literature
in ways that few authors have.
We honor Isabel Allende.
[APPLAUSE]
Conjuring memories
blown by winds of exile,
leavening realism
with dashes of magic,
she fills her splendorous
house of stories
with spirits and shadows,
anguish and love.
Isabel Allende,
Doctor of Letters.
[APPLAUSE]
This stage has been graced by
presidents and prime ministers,
laureates and literary lights,
even the occasional prince
or king.
In fact, with us here today, we
have a president, a laureate,
a literary luminary,
and even a King.
We now proudly welcome
to this esteemed company
her regal highness,
the queen of soul.
[APPLAUSE]
Born in Memphis,
raised in Detroit,
she was a child prodigy
with a voice that
shook the rafters of her church.
As a teenager, she set out
on gospel caravan tours
with her father.
She soon had a
recording contract.
And within a few years, she was
not just climbing the charts,
but topping them with
five straight singles that
sold more than a
million copies each.
Over the years, her records
helped compose the soundtrack
of a generation--
"Respect," "Chain of Fools,"
"I Never Loved a Man," "Baby,
I Love You," "Think Until you
Come Back to Me," "Spanish
Harlem," and on and on.
She has won an eye
popping 18 Grammy awards.
[APPLAUSE]
Including the award
for best female
R&B vocal performance for an
amazing eight straight years.
Her voice has galvanized three
presidential inaugurations,
and it graced the funeral of
Doctor Martin Luther King.
The first woman inducted into
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame,
and a recipient of the
National Medal of Arts,
she was presented in 2005
with the nation's highest
civilian honor-- the
Presidential Medal of Freedom.
[APPLAUSE]
Her vocal virtuosity
is so admired
that her home state of
Michigan declared her voice
one of the state's
natural resources.
[LAUGHTER]
There are singers,
Ray Charles once said,
and then there is Aretha.
With the utmost respect--
I won't spell it out--
we honor Aretha Franklin.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey band, do that again.
We couldn't hear you
with the cheering.
[LAUGHTER]
[BAND PLAYING - ARETHA FRANKLIN,
"RESPECT"]
[CHEERING]
Almighty fire and amazing
grace, she reigned sublime
as the electrifying
empress of soul.
For this, our highest honor,
she is a natural woman.
Aretha Franklin, Doctor of Arts.
[APPLAUSE]
Our next guest's
singular career has
combined extraordinary
entrepreneurial success,
distinguished public service,
and visionary philanthropy
for the common good.
Born across the river at
Saint Elizabeth's Hospital
in Allston/Brighton,
raised in nearby Medford,
he worked his way through
college at Johns Hopkins
before earning his MBA at
Harvard Business School.
[CHEERING]
Wall Street beckoned.
He soon became a rising star in
equity trading and information
systems, and then launched
the firm that bears his name.
The rise of Bloomberg
LP, transformed the world
of financial information.
And it established
its founder as one
of the nation's most
savvy executives
and imaginative entrepreneurs.
Having built his company
into a global force,
he set his sights on a
new leadership challenge.
Three times, he won election as
mayor of the City of New York,
serving from 2002 until December
of 2013 Over that 12 year
tenure, he dedicated himself to
enhancing the city's schools,
spurring the creation of new
jobs, improving public health,
nourishing the arts and culture,
and confronting the challenge
of climate change, all while
helping the city navigate
the wrenching aftermath of 9/11.
As a philanthropist, he has
devoted more than 3.3 billion
and counting of
his own resources
to an array of worthy causes,
education foremost among them.
[APPLAUSE]
Few figures in our time
have made so strong a mark
on both business and government.
On both the vitality
of private enterprise
and the creative pursuit
of the public good,
let us honor his honor
Michael Bloomberg.
[APPLAUSE]
[BAND PLAYING]
From Hopkins to
Harvard, Wall Street
to City Hall, a resolute leader
and fervent philanthropist,
whose entrepreneurial spirit
and zeal for innovation
have helped our
nation's burg to bloom,
Michael Bloomberg,
Doctor of Laws.
[APPLAUSE]
It is seldom on
this stage that we
take the occasion to
honor a former member
of the cheerleading
squad at Yale.
[LAUGHTER]
But there is more to this story.
Born in Milton, Massachusetts
90 years ago next month,
he served with valor
and distinction
as a Navy pilot in the
Pacific during World War II.
[CHEERING]
In 1945, he married his
sweetheart, Barbara Pierce.
[APPLAUSE]
Soon after, he enrolled
in a quaint college
in the hinterlands of
South Central Connecticut
in a city that stakes
its claim to fame
on being the birthplace
of the lollipop.
He kept in Yale's baseball team
as a left handed first baseman,
and he led them to the finals
of the College World Series
two years in a row.
When Babe Ruth presented
an original manuscript
of his autobiography
to the Yale archives,
our guest was chosen
to receive it.
By the 1960s, in Texas, he
launched his remarkable career
in public service.
[APPLAUSE]
Across the decades,
it would take him
from the House of
Representatives
to service as US Ambassador
to the United Nations,
from chairing the Republican
National Committee to directing
Central Intelligence, from
eight years as vice president
to his election in 1988 as the
41st president of the United
States.
[APPLAUSE]
With a clear eye
and a steady hand,
he led the United States
through a transformative time
in world affairs.
His presidency saw the
liberation of Kuwait,
the fall of the Berlin Wall, the
crumbling of the Soviet Union,
the signing of the first
two Strategic Arms Reduction
treaties, and the
end of the Cold War.
[APPLAUSE]
He was a force behind the
historic North American Free
Trade Agreement.
Working with Congress, he
championed the Americans
with Disabilities Act, the
Clean Air Act amendments,
the Community and
National Service Act,
and the Immigration Act of 1990.
[APPLAUSE]
And throughout his long
career in public service,
extending well beyond
his presidency,
he has been a champion of
volunteer service for the well
being of others.
What he has famously
called Points of Light--
or as they like to say in
New Haven, Points of Looks.
With a burst of Eli
cheer, we proudly
honor the honorable George
Herbert Walker Bush.
[APPLAUSE]
[BAND PLAYING]
With faith, courage, and service
true, his eyes ever fixed
on points of light,
he piloted our nation
through changeful skies.
His cap was blue,
his house was white,
and now his robe is crimson.
George H W Bush, Doctor of Laws.
[APPLAUSE]
In the name of this
society of scholars,
I declare that these persons
are entitled to the rights
and privileges pertaining
to their several degrees,
and that their names
are to be forever borne
on its role of honorary members.
[APPLAUSE]
Degree candidates and
their guests and all alumni
are warmly invited to
attend the afternoon
session of commencement
day exercises
under the direction of the
Harvard Alumni Association.
The alumni parade
will begin at 1:45 PM,
and the exercises
will begin at 2:30 PM.
The commencement speakers
will be Michael R Bloomberg
and the president of
Harvard University.
Now, the commencement
choir director
will lead us in the singing
of the commencement hymn.
Following the hymn,
the Pusey Minister
will pronounce the benediction.
The commencement exercises
then being ended,
the Sheriff of
Middlesex County will
declare the meeting adjourned.
The audience is requested
to remain seated
until the president and
fellows and their guests
have withdrawn
from the platform.
[BAND PLAYING]
[MUSIC - SAMUEL GILMAN, "FAIR
HARVARD"]
[CHEERING]
As we close this
morning's ceremony,
I would like to offer
a benediction inspired
by one of the greatest
intellectuals, poets,
and preachers of the 20th
century, the Reverend Clarence
Lavaughn Franklin, whose
daughter we honored here today.
As an eagle stirreth
her nest, Oh God,
we ask that you would stir
us to be kind and give thanks
every day.
Stir us, oh God, to
treat our bodies well.
For we are made in the
imago dei, the image of God.
Be kind, be of service.
Stir us, oh God, to treat
our neighbors right.
Stir us.
Stir us so that we
might discipline
ourselves to know
ourselves better.
And in knowing
ourselves better, we
begin to love
ourselves as we are.
And when we break through the
cloud of insecurity that often
confines our
bodies, then we will
be able to love our
neighbors as ourselves.
Stir us.
Stir us, so that we
might, in humble ways,
bring your kingdom here on
Earth as it is in heaven.
May we all say together, amen.
[CHEERING]
As the high sheriff
of Middlesex County,
I declare that the
meeting will be adjourned.
[APPLAUSE]
[BELL RINGS]
Now the bell in the
church begins to ring.
And there is a tintinnabulation
of bells all over Cambridge,
including the great Lowell
House bells from Russia.
And there's the Sheriff of
Middlesex County and Drew
Faust, president of Harvard
leading the procession.
Procession of overseers.
This is a grand
board of overseers,
and Alan Garber, the provost.
Everybody's heading
off the stage.
And there will be a
president's spread.
All of these luncheons
are called spreads.
And they take place everywhere.
The president's over near
Lowell House on Quincy Street.
This has been an amazing
day in Harvard Yard,
beginning with the influx of
so many students, and faculty,
and parents, and families.
And just extraordinary.
If you just look at
all the happy faces,
all the amazing achievement
of all of our students,
and the celebration
of their current
and also future accomplishments.
It's just such an exciting time.
And thank you.
Here we see Aretha Franklin
being congratulated.
And the Harvard Band.
Actually, I think we should
note that the Latin orator is
a member of the Harvard Band
when he put on that Roman hat
for his oration.
The faculty are filing
up to congratulate
the honorary degree recipients.
This afternoon,
this will fill again
with the Harvard Alumnae
Association Annual
Meeting, which will
be called to order.
The new Alumnae
Association president
is Cynthia Torres, who was
elected rather recently.
And 1980 graduate of the college
who welcomed the newest class
yesterday afternoon.
So Diana, it's been a really
wonderful commencement,
and I'm glad I got to
spend it with you here.
We're just the talking
heads here of course.
There's an entire crew of
people-- Kathy O'Connell
and lots of other
people who are helping
make this commencement happen
and make this broadcast happen.
It's always a
pleasure to witness
this spectacle with you.
And it's such a great
pleasure to see the joy
on the faces of the
graduates, and at the delight
of the faculty of
being here as well
to be reminded by our
student speakers of both
the historic presence of
George Washington in this yard,
and the inspiration that
the call to a global world
really has for our students.
We heard that again
and again this year.
And I suspect it's
really part of why
we're all here at Harvard.
And the call to service.
So thank you everyone.
And we look forward to
seeing you again next year.
Happy day of commencement.